on a mountain of mud and debris they
search in the desperate hope of finding
anyone who survived this
more often than not they're finding
those who didn't
and the city of petropolis is in
mourning for the dozens killed in what
was a devastating mudslide
rosaline said she could hear her brother
yelling for help
okay
it was a deluge a month's worth of rain
falling in just three hours water
rushing down through the streets of this
famous old city
and unleashing an avalanche of mud that
swept through the neighborhoods that
have grown up its hillsides the governor
here says it resembles a war zone and
rescue workers haven't yet been able to
reach some streets such is the extent of
the mudflower
the removal of one lucky survivor
interrupting him
even as the rescue operation continues
the cleanup has begun for many
brazil's president is in moscow visiting
vladimir putin he sent his prayers to
the people of petropolis
it is a city that's seen catastrophes
like this in the past and has even drawn
up a plan to reduce the risk of
landslides but it's been slow progress
carrying out the work
and it will come too late for may greg
milam sky news